bonsoir les costauds ont égalé les
barjots autrement dit les handballeurs
français sont devenus cet après midi
champion du monde en battant le tenant
du titre la suède
un véritable exploit au terme d'un
formidable suspense à bercy le reportage
de christie réunissent et denis
bassompierre la main dans la main c'est
comme si une belle histoire leur
histoire se terminait en apothéose
comme s'ils avaient relâché son fils
dans le grand bain car ce soir ils se
sont quittés comme ils s'étaient connus
en 1995 avec un titre de champion du
monde et pour les nouveaux costaud c'est
merci daniel choisi la montre à tout le
monde que s'il faisait partie des
meilleurs et va pouvoir partir
tranquille mais que ce fut difficile
face aux maîtres de la planète hand à
chaque coup de butoir des suédois c'est
l'artillerie bleus qui répond
salut
on y est
on a tout mis dans la bataille
il a eu
il a eu une motivation extrême vraiment
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a cru une
belle histoire du handball mondial et
penseurs car à bercy l'équipe de france
a réalisé son rêve
même si c'est la fin d'une équipe celle
des barjots car le match s'est
rapidement transformée en combat de rue
17 17 20 22 20 d égalité qui se suivent
ou quand l'angoissé de la place à
l'euphorie avant les inévitables
prolongation
maintenant c'est plus facile d'aborder
la prolongation quand on recolle au
score qui t'attend petits points et
remonte et psychologiquement ce qui rend
plus facile parce que je t'ai nous qui
étions sur la bonne dynamique et une
dynamique de succès pendant les
prolongations
comme si rien ne pouvait les arrêter dix
minutes intenses
ce sont les bleus qui ont tout emballé
grâce à greg anquetil 28 25
les français remportent ainsi leur
deuxième titre mondial après celui
conquis en islande en 1995 daniel
costantini peut partir heureux